all right joining us now former White
House press secretary Sean Spicer how
you did that job I will never for the
life of me understand it all right so
when when they had the worst whole CNN
used it 195 times in a day now it's
stormy stormy stormy
there's no Russia Russia Russia it just
in the meantime they've missed the
biggest abuse of power scandal in their
lifetime and how do you describe the
media today even sensational misdirected
look beyond the story you keep talking
about all the time which I completely
agree is is underserved you've got the
Prime Minister of Japan in meeting with
the president this week down in Marlow
go talking about trade in national
security you've got serious issues over
in Syria you've got an upcoming meeting
with King John on about the
nuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
and the threat that it potentially poses
to not to start allies but potentially
our own citizens and this is what
they're talking about you know when it
comes to the priorities of what the
media is talking about what is on what
are the concerns of the American people
I think there's a complete mismatch and
as you point out correctly it's this
pack mentality they they want to be
taken seriously they want to be treated
with respect and yet their entire focus
is on a salacious unverified detail but
a comment that supposedly the former
president and Prime Minister of Russia
don't put depending on what it was said
if you if you look at the order though
it was and you were in the room at the
time this is the fascinating thing it
was call me that said it's unverified
and salacious he brought up the idea
right he brought if we're gonna look at
the order where it started it was it was
call me telling then president-elect
Donald Trump that's where the answers
are coming from but more importantly
they have been peddling the biggest lie
in conspiracy theory about some type of
collusion now for a year there's no
evidence and they still try to keep
peddling the same lie so I don't know
how can we even call a journalism at
this point
well again I think that's got to go back
to a second ago Shawn is that they want
to be taught they would talk about this
commitment to the First Amendment they
want to be treated with seriousness and
respect and yet they focus on these
salacious type tabloid unverified
allegations
I think the funny thing about this is
what they didn't report in any of those
clips that you played is that what did
Comey actually say that when he
presented this to the president in that
in that room after that briefing he
asked the president to see him alone
privately to share with him these
unverified allegations and the president
immediately said do what you have to do
to prove that they're untrue call an
investigation on me and it was Comey who
said I don't know if that's a good idea
mr. president but the president
immediately says do what you have to to
prove that these aren't true
do whatever you mean and that just shows
you that anyone is accused of something
if they're actually guilty of it they
would say hey can we can we kind of
sweep this under the rug can we cover it
up a little you're gonna you know you're
not gonna say anything are you but in
fact the president had quite the
opposite he got out there and said we
need to clear this up we need to get it
out there I don't like any of this this
is concerning what do you have to do and
that really shows you they don't want to
cover that part of it then the president
forcefully and immediately pushed back
and wanted them to actually conduct an
investigation into this well this is
what the president said he said took all
and these were in the combing notes
rather than the superfluous stuff they
talked about if there was some satellite
which he took to mean an associate or
somebody on his campaign that did
something it would be good to find that
out but that he himself hadn't done
anything so not only is he not
obstructing in that instance he's
encouraging Jim Comey than anybody
around here that's involved in any of
this stuff I want to know do your job
find out who they know what they know it
would be good to know the truth exactly
he wants to know hey if anyone's using
my name or claiming that they're they're
part of my associated with me and doing
something nefarious I want them called
out but the other thing that's very
fascinating Shawn about all of this is
go back to what happened that very first
day the president-elect who's never
served in government before sits down
with those for intelligence to you Comey
as the FBI director says mr. president
can we clear the room and I can speak to
you alone privately okay we get that
then fast-forward a little bit later the
president says to
Jim Comey hey can we clear the room I'd
like to talk to you and suddenly the
accusations is how dare the president
clear the room to talk to Jim Comey but
if we think about it well of course he
thinks that that standard operating
procedure Comey was the one who engaged
first in that relationship by saying
when we need to talk we get to clear the
room he started that kind of
relationship with the president and then
they attacked the president for doing
the exact same thing when Comey comes to
see him in the Oval Office